the Joe Rogan experience hey man I miss
you I miss you on TV right now I really
do this is a perfect time for you it's
kind of crazy that you're not hosting
that show anymore but there's so many
people doing that after you know I was I
really did burn out like I I felt like
it's just redundant you know the nice
thing for what you do is you get to
curate and kind of be more active and to
follow your own rhythm for it
I was really tied to that rhythm of the
24-hour news cycle right and how [ __ ]
redundant it is and how cyclical and at
a certain point I was like I don't know
what else to do with this and so I
didn't want to stay just because I could
I just done it long enough and so I
thought well let me just it was just
time I felt like the audience needed a
fresh perspective I needed a fresh
perspective like I just I just felt John
like I was more I was more mad about
[ __ ] than then inspired you know I
appreciate that you decided to go out at
the literally at the very top but it
seems like especially like right now
John Oliver's killing it and Trevor
Noah's doing your show and it's like
this is this is that there's so much to
mock it's almost like an overload and
doing real commentary on politics today
in my pits almost like you're doing
commentary on Pro Wrestling like this is
a rigged game and you're on here
pretending like this [ __ ] like sense yes
it is all right well it's also because
that's the economic system that's been
set up around politics is the very same
that Vince McMahon set up around
wrestling you create I mean it is a kind
of you know k-fed it's a sort of layout
there are characters you know what it's
like when you're trying to produce
something every day you're gonna go with
kind of a boilerplate structure so
you're gonna say alright our show
revolves around you
from the right or from the left whatever
comes in we're gonna filter it through
that we're gonna keep it
producible but it starts to like you say
it becomes inauthentic but the same
thing would happen to me sometimes with
like I'd be doing shows and and you
would know you weren't necessarily
feeling the outrage of something or that
the commentary was going to be a spicy
or as deep as you might want it but you
might kick it up a notch anyway because
it was performative you know I always
had to fight that instinct to not to not
give in to the gravity of like what was
expected it's such a tightrope to walk
because you're commenting and you're
doing comedy on something that's
actually serious and it's great to mock
the ridiculous aspects of it but really
like if you're doing the The Daily Show
right now like we really are in a
legitimately troubled time like it's not
it's not like a trouble time of ten
years ago or eight years ago I this is a
real trouble time no and I think as that
builds up it becomes harder and harder
but I can recall you know people people
will say sometimes in look I think
there's a certain nostalgia that people
view my time on the show has and I'm not
the so dedicated I just mean you know
when you walk away from something I
think a kind of nostalgia about how you
know I took a fair amount of [ __ ] while
I was there and but but the point is
like Charleston happened when I was
hosting that show Ferguson happened the
Iraq war happened 9/11 happened like
Jesus these types of things were always
and and what would happen is you started
to feel like you were expected to say
something profound about hmm knew that
you didn't really have that in you at
times or just that's a bar that was
beyond you know you really did just want
to help your staff get through it more
than than anything else and so these
events would
and the weight of feeling like you had
to say something meaningful in that
moment for people because that's the
role that either they had you know let
me know that you had in their lives or
that the show kind of took on you know
became kind of difficult to navigate
because the [ __ ] is so cyclical like the
man I could go back and and do my ten
war on Christmas bits new year when that
[ __ ] would flare up but like at a
certain point when things like
Charleston happened where Eric garner
like I had nothing in the tank comedic
like all I could do was stare into the
camera and just express sadness and help
it's like you notice it's impotent rage
at a certain point hmm rage against it
but over a period of 16 years if you
feel the thing you're raging against
grow stronger right and kind of collapse
on top of you and not make any way
nobody likes to piss in the ocean yeah
or you like it but at a certain point if
that's your job I think it I think
people began to look at the show like it
was supposed to change things and and
that's a heart that's a hard place to be
for for a comedy show
[Applause]